new age conservatism is classicalism
and like just from looking at all the
people who identify that way now so
that's
where i've always been um and
the democrats progressives liberals
whatever you want to call them on that
side
it's just the most toxic behavior i've
seen from a group of people in a long
time
like i haven't even see i've never met a
religious person
that was far right that treated me that
way the way that people
do
hey i'm dave rubin and joining me today
is a former lefty
turn conservative a youtube creator
and a card carrying lesbian here to talk
about what's going on
with the gay community arielle scarcella
welcome to the reuben report
thank it's been long overdue you said
this vlog
but like girl everyone everyone says
that i'm the female dave rubin and at
first
i was like do they mean that in a bad
way and some of them do but like
i know it's a good thing even though
they might think bad things so either
way
i'm flattered no matter how they mean it
i'm flattered either way much obliged
and i'm
glad you're here and we are putting this
interview out during
pride month the gays get a whole month i
introduce a card carrying lesbian
is it true that lesbians have a card do
you have some sort of laminated card
i mean i i mean i think it's more that
we
now we have to have a card because now
we can't even define the damn word yeah
right
like nobody even knows how to find woman
we can't define lesbian
so i feel like we need to have a card
that says like this is
what a lesbian means to me this is the
card this is what i
am and this is what i want right kind of
like gay hanky code back in like the 70s
you know when they had the hangi code
the older game i referenced the older
gays get that i i get the reference but
it's a little bit before
my time but i wanted to have you on for
a while because you
are when people say that you're the
you're the girl dave reuben or something
to that effect
you left the left and you survived so
could we just do like a two minute recap
because it's pretty recent for you it's
only in the last couple years you were
elected
and you woke up that's exactly what
happened
i think looking back now the past
four years you know of my content making
because i'm an og youtuber i've been
making videos since 2009 like before
youtube was even a career option
yeah that's before me like years before
me
exactly like we were just online having
fun being kids
i was like 23 at the time 24 and
now you know looking back
my entire outlook on the community has
has changed
back then it was it was everybody was
humble everyone got along there was like
some
drama here and there but usually it had
to do with who was dating who and who
broke up with who
not with how someone identified or who
wants to sleep with who
um and the last five years i noticed
a huge change in the youtube community
especially the gay community
the lgbt community on youtube it became
volatile volatile whatever though i
don't know how to pronounce the word
because i'm from
i'll accept either one you're a brooklyn
girl
right but you know it became just toxic
honestly
um and it started i would say it started
with
the trans community and then it filtered
into
the bisexual non-binary queer whatever
anything other than lesbian community
and then now it's starting to filter
down into the gays and lesbians and it
started to hit me
when i started making content about
trans people with trans people by the
way trans people were in the videos
but i got sick of feeling like
everyone was attacking me for simply
having a different opinion
and it wasn't it to me in my opinion it
wasn't even
like a non-mainstream opinion that's the
weird part right like this is
pretty like it's based on logic and
science yeah what
what was your highly controversial
opinion on the trans issue
oh my god there's so many highly highly
controversial transphobic opinions that
i have but one of them is
i don't think somebody is a lesbian you
know if they
want to want to suck a dick so can i say
that on your show
you can i think it's the first time it's
been said but
it's definitely the first time but like
that's not controversial it shouldn't be
controversial and
somehow yet it is um i i think socially
it makes a lot of sense when
there are trans women who present as
women like you know my friend blairway
like my friend ashley
socially they'll always be women because
they don't long they no longer live
their lives as men
and i i have you know i've had that
opinion for years and i started speaking
out
you know about that kind of stuff
because people don't realize that
you can be you the two things can be
true at once you can be pro-trans rights
but also pro-women's rights and
unfortunately
there's a line that's being crossed into
women's rights territory and that's when
i started
really seeing the divide um with me and
the left
and i i was gonna stand by my morals no
matter what because i'm a new york
italian
and i finally made a video actually
connected with tim poole who's been a
friend of mine way before he
got big on youtube um i connected with
him and i went over his house
and i was like i'm i need help like i
don't know what the hell to do
but i'm being attacked constantly i've
lost
50 or plus creator friends of mine and
i also contacted my friend sydney watson
who i think you know and
she and tim helped me write the video
and i i posted the video and i just
prayed to god honestly i didn't know
what to expect i really didn't i was
just
tired of being mentally and emotionally
abused
and i even made a video about that about
how all the tactics that the progressive
left
uses these days are emotionally like
psychological emotional abuse tactics
you know like the whole thing like
trying to get you fired making sure that
you only talk to certain people
like crazy [ __ ] that i've been in
abusive relationships before
i started seeing the red flags i wasn't
completely convinced at first because i
was like okay just like they're just a
bunch of kids
but then my friends my ex-friends
started doing it to me and i was like
okay like this is
i have to put an end to this and not
allow myself to be
um taken advantage of anymore
so i think the million-dollar question
that that all gay people get
asked when they come out as anything
other than progressive
is which was harder to come out of the
closet
or to come out as a conservative or
someone that is just non-progressive
it was harder coming out of the closet
to
myself it was harder coming out of the
closet
as a gay person it was harder coming out
of the closet as a non-progressive to
the world i mean because it wasn't about
yeah because it was about how they saw
me not how i saw myself like i always i
always knew that i was sort of like
at this point in my life i think i'm
pretty much like
physically conservative social
libertarian socially libertarian like
live and let live don't touch me
like let me do what i want with my
bodies pretty much you know don't take
my money
give me my guns like i understand guns
right now right-wing extremist
stuff yeah of course like white
nationalists everything you know but
like that's where i'm at now and i think
part of it also is
moving down to florida part time made a
big difference in the way i thought
because
you know new york city is super
progressive florida's a little bit more
of a red state
and i got that perspective and helped me
i guess
centralize maybe my opinions on certain
issues um
and i made you know the best part of
this all
is i made better friends from it like
better friends that
like now when i get like online bullied
or harassed whatever
the people that on the left never would
help never ever would stick up for me
all the people on the right all these
terrible people that everyone's making
it out to be
making out to seem like they're terrible
people all of them always come to my
defense
every single time
yeah and and it's it's just it's
mind-blowing to me how
opposite it is compared to what the
media portrays them to be
has it been kind of disappointing for
you to see
what you described with the gay
community i was never like really
in the gay community in that way i
actually had a
gay i had a gay radio show on siriusxm
so i guess i had like a year or two of
my life that i was sort of in that world
um but i never really felt like i was in
it i was also closeted later and
just just the way my life was it's just
how it is um
but to see now like when people talk
about the gay community it seems like
they've gone from being
edgy and controversial and sort of
subversive and interesting and there was
music and fashion and blah blah blah
to now it's just like the worst sort of
social preening
political hysterics yeah yeah like i
have
friends of mine that went to you know
they go to florida pride parades
and they get they get harassed like
verbally not thank god i don't think
anyone's like throwing anything at them
but they get verbally harassed like
cursed at
and just for being a conservative for
believing in something different
he doesn't you know my friend david
broke back patriot
um what's upsetting to me the most
i think over the last two years is
when i and this is maybe an ego thing a
little bit i'm not gonna lie
but it's also a comfort thing when i
used to go out to these pride marches
and
lesbian events or lgbt events like you
know playlist live
vidcon whatever kids used to come up to
me and
cry like actually i'm not even kidding
like cry telling me that i saved their
life
or i at least changed their life i
helped them out of class closet help
them
be who they were be who they are it's
like i'm the same person that i was back
then
yeah i just am more honest and open with
my opinions now
even though to me they're still
pretty you know mainstream mainstream
opinions
now when i go to pride parades and i go
to safe spaces
i'm not even kidding i don't feel safe
anymore like i i've
i went to um i went to a gay bar in
tampa
and um it could be just me being in my
own head i really don't know
my friends saw it too though so maybe it
wasn't just me in my own head there was
an older trans woman
assumingly a trans woman and i could
have sworn she was staring at me and my
first thought of course
is not that she's thinking about hitting
on me like my first thought is oh my god
this person knows who i am and thinks
i'm a transphobe
and like it's gonna attack me and i
don't want to think that way because
like that's assuming somebody's
something that they might not be
but it's gotten to that point people
like i said people used to come up to me
hug me
now people at pride parades and events
will come up to me in private
and do one of these things yeah do they
do that to youtube like i just want you
to know
yeah like i can say this out loud but i
really really appreciate what you're
doing and i'm like god damn it like
you can't say it louder like they they
won't do it yeah they're terrified but
most
you and i know at this point most people
agree with what you and i say
i i that's what i think too because i
don't think any
no nobody's happier because of this
thing you know it sort of was like
when when pride month rolled around or i
used to go to the
the pride parade in new york city which
is always the last sunday
of june and my birthday's my birthday is
june 26th so i actually
met my husband who i've now been with
for 10 years on my birthday
at gay pride i love that believe it or
not
and he was wearing an american flag tank
top it was it was all meant to be
i love it but but yeah when i would go
there then
people would sort of love me because i
had this radio show and i was a lefty
and i don't really go to them anymore
but i did go to the abbey which is like
the big gay bar of west hollywood
uh i went about a year ago and for the
first time i left i was kind of worried
because i was like i don't know what
these people are going to think about me
exactly what you're saying
but i will say not only did nobody say
anything negative to me but several
people did come up to me and i could
tell they were a little nervous like oh
maybe i shouldn't be seen with dave but
they were like
dave i'm i'm with you so they are they
are waking up they are
because gays are supposed to be
individuals not not group monolithic
thinkers
yes that's the whole point isn't it
we're like we're
we're we were born different i think and
this is like a little spiritual lesson
but i think when you're born different
it's a gift right
it's a gift to in being yourself because
you're different is a gift because you
allow other people
the chance to be themselves you show
them that it's okay
and i don't i think if we are a monolith
i think that's the opposite of what our
path is
as lgbt people you know we have the
opportunity to
be leaders and we're being followers and
i refuse that
you know are you hopeful that we can
turn this thing around it seems like so
much of
the woke thing is attached to the trans
thing where every day there's another
trans story i even talk
talk about it with my guys on the show
when we're figuring out the rundown and
i'm like i don't really feel like doing
another trans story
just because we're overblowing this
thing i've you know i'm saying with you
i don't care you i'll call you if you
treat me with respect i'll treat
you with respect i call caitlyn jenner a
she i don't have any problem with that
um but but that the issues these they've
just bludgeoned us with these issues to
the point
that i actually think they're starting
to cause a backlash i actually think
there's some backlash on the gays now
too
because of this because they feel like
oh see what happened the gays became
equal
and now look what happened now now boys
have vaginas and girls have penises
right no and i agree with them i agree
with the people that it is a slippery
slope i
i think which is why i call myself like
in this sense a conservative meaning
to me what a conservative means these
days is a classic liberal
and i think that's how you identify
correct me if i'm wrong yeah although i
don't i don't have a problem saying
conservative
at this point but yes my beliefs
new age conservatism is classicalism in
my like
just from looking at all the people who
identify that way now so that's
where i've always been um and
the democrats progressives liberals
whatever you want to call them on that
side
it's just the most toxic behavior i've
seen from a group of people in a long
time
like i haven't even see i've never met a
religious person
that was far right that treated me that
way the way that people
do and why they're telling you how
tolerant they are that's the beauty of
it yeah
yeah that's well yeah that's that's
another abusive tactic right
gaslighting um like actual gaslighting
like i'm being nice i care about you
like nah like no
clearly you don't like you don't respect
me at all i
i think that i think that we have a long
way to go
because people are so guilted right now
into into virtue signaling and and
trying to be the the most woken the
wokest or the most woke
and i think that's because there's an
extreme
lack of self-awareness and self
self-worth from these people that are
that are doing this kind of
virtue signaling whatever you want to
call it they need to
be confident in themselves especially
the trans community in my opinion and
get [ __ ] for saying that but you know
what it is what it is
um anyone that that's that's very
different
needs to get their act together
be okay with being different and become
a leader and stop
needing validation they have to stop
meeting and wanting validation from
everyone else
from the entire world and i think
once they do that and they show that
you know like caitlyn jenner i think is
a really good example to be honest
i think she is she holds a lot of
respect from
a lot of people even if they don't agree
with her being trans not that you can't
agree with being trans because you can't
fix it
help it but even if somebody disagrees
with her
i think they have a lot of respect for
her because she speaks logical
logically and i think that's that's
where the left is completely messing up
none of them are making any sense at the
moment none of them
it's all based on no it's all based on
identity politics
and you know people wanting to
be nice what do you uh what do you say
or what advice would you have if there's
like a young
gay kid watching this a 15 year old that
that
sort of understands that the woke thing
is wrong because we also know that now
the
the the zoomers the young generation
after generation y
they are leaning more conservative
because they've seen this thing go so
out of whack
but what would you say to a young gay
kid young girl who's
who wants to come out but doesn't want
to be completely uh
just swarmed by that thing
it's tough because i i get messages more
like that every day
than people assume i get hit on all the
time in my direct messages it's not like
that it's always these types of messages
like what do i do
i'm more conservative or i don't believe
in this crazy [ __ ] that they're spewing
i don't know how to speak up
you have to figure it out you have to
figure out how to speak up as long as
you're safe
um because in my opinion i think you
know this
if every single person that agreed with
us spoke up
this would end tomorrow it would end
tomorrow and today it really would
like it really would because there are a
lot more of us than them
and that doesn't that doesn't mean that
we're we're correct on the issue just
because there's more of us
but in this case i do think you know
it's just a bonus that there happens to
be more of us and we also
happen to be on the right side of
history so to speak pun intended i guess
my advice my advice would be you're born
to
do to be different and this is just
another chance to be
to be different and be proud of it to
think differently
everyone's scared these days to think
differently and if you can do that
and prove that that's okay and know that
that's okay to yourself and show others
that that's okay you're gonna be
the starter it's going to be the start
of something big for them have you
gotten
any real hate from people on the right
because i think for me what one of the
things that was kind of surprising was
that really didn't happen yes there's
this
very sl tiny sliver of anonymous weirdos
on twitter
who who seem to be on the right and hate
gays but in
reality whether i was sitting down with
ben shapiro who has a different
religious perspective
on gay marriage let's say or scary glenn
beck
or any of these people i found nothing
but support
i found nothing but humanity and decency
i go to evangelical events and get
standing ovations like
i just find tolerance there even though
perhaps they have a different
some of them have perhaps a different
religious belief
yeah i i people are going to think i'm
lying and drifting for this but like i
really haven't had any bad experiences
yet like
even when i like you said you disagree
with them they're like okay i don't i
don't agree but i still love you i still
respect you as a person okay like i'm
pro-choice i'm always gonna be
pro-choice because i'm a traditional
feminist
um not these crazy third and fourth wave
feminists oh my god
yeah i think
yeah i don't i i think it's much better
on this side overall
like i i haven't really had any any like
even i met up with ben shapiro
and ben shapiro in l.a and he said the
most ben shapiro thing to me ever
in his little you know how he talks he
talks about do give me a venture
impression come on
i'm going to try but he was like you
know you know the conservatives haven't
cared about gay since like 1990 right
like
like so quickly like he shook his head
he did one of those things like you know
we don't care anymore right
and i was like i was like well now i
know like i didn't know before but he's
like yeah we nobody cares nobody
i don't know my story of meeting trump
but i met trump uh in 2019
uh right before christmas and when he
realized that i was gay i was standing
with david and
and he got up he slapped his hands on
the table he goes i just want you to
know
i don't give a [ __ ] and i don't think
anyone else gives a [ __ ] and i don't
think they've given a [ __ ] for 20 years
and i was like this is the homophobe
this is the homophobia chief
yeah yeah i don't i don't think like i
he's a new yorker and i don't know any
new yorker that
gives a [ __ ] about who's gay like none
of them
none of them give a [ __ ] in fact they'll
probably like you more because you're
gay because you're like
there's you offer some new perspective
and that's very new you know
because you're a new yorker like that's
a very new york thing yeah
are you are you hopeful that we'll get
through this thing i mean i i'm with you
that if everyone just spoke up that's
the only thing
stop it there's no there's no like magic
white night coming but are you hopeful
that people will actually do it
i'm always going to be hopeful because
but you know what if i'm if
if i'm wrong that's just more job
security for us right we just can keep
making
i say it all the time and i honestly
mean it i would much rather things get
fixed and i'll find something else to do
if i have to
i really i really do mean that yeah if i
i can go back to talking about lesbian
sex you know
that's that's that's just as good in my
opinion instead instead of doing damage
control i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna ask you about that i'm
very confused about the whole thing
frankly
okay but i think it's great that you're
doing it you know
there's so much to talk about like so
much
guys it's so simple you're you're also
on
uh local so i wanna i wanna pimp that
out because you decided that you can't
be beholden
to the to the big tech machine because
you've you've had some stuff censored
right
oh yeah i've been demonetized i think
three times for like a month at a time
over the last two years
like your entire channel not just not
just random videos like
your whole catalog yeah yep and i've
been making
the same content for 10 years so all of
a sudden i come out as more conservative
leaning and then they demonetize me it's
a little fishy if you ask me so
yeah something's up is it just ariel
local.locals.com
yep yep ariel.locals.com we'll link to
it right down below well listen
have a have a very prideful pride month
we get a whole month isn't that exciting
that's a long yeah it's the longest time
i'm going to be walking around
with with a maga hat possibly or some
kind of like
i don't know something and going into
safe spaces maybe i'm going to film some
stuff i don't know
at this point thank you if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about women's issues
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our women's issues playlist and if you
want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell